ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้นักเรียนมคำนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครับผมโอเคกลับมาเจอกับ
พี่อาร์ตี้กับนักเรียนอีกแล้วนะครับใน
ช่องท้อง transitive ไทยเย้เย้
วันนี้ที่เรามาเจอกันเป็นวันอะไรค่ะพี่
อ้าวันนี้ใช่ไหมครับวันนี้ที่เรามาเจอกัน
เนี่ยวันนี้เป็นวันศุกร์นะครับ
วันศุกร์แล้ว
ใช่ครับ
วันศุกร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันศุกร์วันนี้
วันที่ 8 ครับ
หนาวันศุกร์ที่ 8
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือนมีแม่สายลหน้า
เดี๋ยวนี้เมษายนไปขับ
แล้วปีพศอะไรคะเมื่อปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับหน้า 2565
แล้วปีคศอะไรคะอ้าปีคศ 2010  22 ครับปี
นี้
รถตอนนี้ที่เราคุยกันองค์ราคาเพียบ PR
ตอนนี้เป็นตอนกลางคืนเป็นตอนกลางคืนครับ
ตอนนี้เวลา
8:00 น
8:30  5 นาทีน
น่าจะเป็นตอนกลางคืนดี
mk2 ทุ่มนะครับ
เฮียตี๋ง่วงหรือยังคะอ่านิดหน่อยครับคลิป
หน่อยโรงเรียนง่วงเยอะนะตาจะหลับอยู่แล้ว
อาจจะ
ง่วงเลยครับๆๆให้ลืมตื่นๆเอาน่าเดี๋ยวเรา
มีเรื่องที่จะเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังมีเรื่อง
อะไรจะมาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังครับวันนี้จะ
ได้ตื่นจะได้ตื่น 5 ตัวอะไรครับ
ต่อจากครั้งที่แล้วค่ะอ๋อที่แล้วเข้าใจ
แล้วเล่าเรื่องอะไรไว้ครับเล่าเรื่องอะไร
ไว้คราวที่แล้ว
อ๋ออ๋อเป็นจังปูใช่ไหมทั้ง Fu กังฟู
แพนด้าใช้ครับออนดูแล้วเหมือนกังฟูใช่ไหม
อ่ะอายุทั้งเหมือนข้างปูนิดหน่อยข้างฟู
นิดหน่อย
โอเคแต่ว่าวันนี้ที่เราจะมาคุยกันก็คือ
กังฟูแพนด้าภาค 2 ขอภาคที่ 2 แล้วใช่ไหม
ครับห้างนี้นะเขาที่แล้วเล่าภาค 1 ไปคราว
นี้ถ้า 2 หาเขาแค่ภาค 2 เป็นยังไงบ้าง
ครับอ่ะ
มีอะไรนะครับภาคสอบก็จะมี
คนที่แบบสู้ใช้กังฟูสู้กับคนอื่นๆอ๋อโอเค
อะเข้า
มีใครบ้างค่ะจำได้ไหมจำได้ไหมว่ามีใคร
บ้างใช่ไหมจำได้จำได้เพื่อที่จำได้แล้วมี
มีอ่า oppo  oppo คนนึงอ้ะโปรเป็นอาเป็น
เอ่อนักรบมังกรใช่ไหมเป็นนักรบมังกรโอเค
ภาค 1 โปรเป็นแพนด้าด้านนะครับ
มังกรอ้าเป็นนักรบมังกรใช่ครับกร
[เพลง]
โทรเป็นแพนด้าใช่ไหมคะใต้
ซื้ออาอาอามี
เอ่ออาจารย์
การชี้ฟูใช้ครับ
นกคนอื่นๆเล่มจำชื่อไม่ค่อยได้นะขึ้นก็มี
ได้จำได้ว่าเป็นสัตว์อะไรใช่ไหมเป็นสัตว์
อะไรเออมีสัตว์อะไรบ้างคะพี่จับด้ามอีโง่
ไอ้ที่เห็นงูอยู่ด้านขวานั่นกว่าอ้า
ใช่ครับตรงนั้นมีงูอยู่นะครับแล้วก็มีตัว
เล็กๆตัวเล็กๆตัวเล็กๆนะครับเท่านั้นเป็น
ปัดกระแตน
ตั๊กแตนฮือปักกะเตแดนแล้วก็มีแล้วก็มี
เสือมีเสือด้วยน่ะใช่ครับ
[เพลง]
แล้วก็มีนกมีนกนกรายงานตัวนี้ก็เรียนน่ะ
ค่ะนกกระเรียนใต้นกกระเรียน
แล้วก็ยิ่งตัวนึงค่าตัวสุดท้ายครับมินที่
5 มังกี้ตอนนี้ใช้ครับเฮียตี๋ต่ำชื่อได้
ได้เพราะว่ามันชื่อมังกี้
ฮ่าๆๆอือเหมือนกันกับลิงโอเคก็เลยจำได้
ในภาพที่ 2 นี้เขาก็จะมีอีกตัวละครนึงนะ
คะที่จะมาสู้อ้ายกับปู่อ๋ออ๋อมีใครครับมี
ใครก็เพิ่มเข้ามาในภาคนี้ครับภาคที่ 2
มีมี
ป๋องเชนอ๋ออ๋อโอเคอ่าของเชนนี่เถอะนะ on
chain นี่เป็นตัวอะไรครับเป็นสัตว์อะไร
ครับของเชิญเป็นสัตว์อะไรอ๋ออ๋อเป็นนกยูง
โอเคจะมาสู้กับ o  o  o เป็นแพนด้าในภาค
ที่ 2 นี่แพนด้าก็จะสู้กับนกยูงใช่ไหม
ครับไม่
ใช่หน้าอะเพียงตี้มีรูปนะเฮียตี้มีรูปของ
ของชื่ออะไรนะครับของเชนใช่ไหมครับทองเชน
5 พี่มีรูปนี่มีคนนี้คนนี้เป็นของเชนที่
มาจะมาสู้กับโป่งใช่ไหมครับ
ชายหรือว่าเล็กสั้นๆเขตก็ได้นะอ้าเรียก
ว่าเชิญได้ครับอ้าง่ายดีคนไทยชอบเรียก
ชื่อสั้นๆเรียกเชนใช่ไหมครับโอเค
ใช่เขาว่า
เมื่อก่อนออกเชนได้ยินมาว่าจะมีคนมาฆ่าขอ
ฆ่าใครครับ
ค่าเช่นขอเช่นเช่นรู้ว่าจะมีคนคนที่จะมา
ฆ่าฆ่าเชนทร์เนี่ยหน้าเป็นไงครับคนที่จะ
มาฆ่าเช่นนี้เป็นยังไงครับ
คนที่จะมาฆ่าเช่นและก็จะมี
มิตัว 4  2 สีค่ะตัวมีสองสีทำหน้ามี 2 สี
สีอะไรบ้างครับที่จะมาฆ่า
มีสีขาว
มีสิทธิ์ขาวแล้วก็มีสีอะไรอีกครับ
แล้วก็มีสีดำอ๋อ
มีสัตว์อะไรที่มีสีขาวสีดำบ้างที่จะมาฆ่า
นะพี่คิดถึง
ฮ่าๆๆ
คิดถึงม้าลายอะไรก็มีสิทธิ์เอากับสีดำมะ
หมาลายคิดถึงลายพ่อม้าลายม้าลายจะมาฆ่า
ออกจะมาฆ่าเชนทร์ใช่ไหมครับหรอแต่ใช่ไหม
จริงแล้วใช่ม้าลาย
โรงเรียนกำลังวาดวาดหมาลายโอเคอ่า
มันไหมมาลัยต้องมีแผนอยู่ที่คอด้วยครับ
เอาอย่างนี้นะคะอ้าแบบนี้เป็นหมาอ่าถ้า
ไม่มีแผงโอเคใช่ออกมาลัยแผงคอด้วยเป็นมา
ลายเดี๋ยวนักเรียนจะอะไรเรียกว่าอะไรอะไร
ก็จะมีหางม้าลายตรงหางของม้าลายก็จะเป็น
ผู้กับนี้
หน้าเป็นหางพู่แบบนี้
อาหารตรงๆจะเป็นหมาออกหาใจเอากันนะมีแผง
ที่คอด้วย
เด้อหมาลาย Army สีขาวกับสีดำใช่ไหมแล้ว
ใช่ม้าลายไหมครับใช่ม้าลายที่จะมาฆ่าของ
เชนมั้ยใช่ไหม
ไม่ใช่
พระเจ้าภาค 2 ไม่มีม้าลายนะอ๋อไม่มีม้า
ลายโอเคหน้าก็ได้นะพี่คิดก่อนคิดว่ามีมี
สัตว์อะไรที่มีสีขาวกับสีดำเอ่อๆก็ต้อง
เป็นแพนด้าสิเปียพี่รู้แล้วว่าแผ่นดาวก็
เรื่องนี้เรื่องนี้เป็นเรื่องกังฟูแพนด้า
แล้วแพนด้านะมี 2 สีใช่ไหมครับ
น้าแพนด้ามี 2 สีมีสีขาวครับอ่าซ้ายอาโป
มี 2 สี K หน้า
เขาก็จะสมัครข้าข้าเช่นขอเชิญเขาอยากอยาก
มีลูกน้องเยอะๆ
ครับ 5 แล้วเช่นเทรนทำยังไงครับที่นี้
เขาก็จะไปหาเหล็กมาค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้เขาติน
เหล็กไหมคะอ้าเหล็กมาเอาเหล็กมาทำอะไร
ครับที่มีแรกมีงับก็มีไม้บรรทัดไม้บรรทัด
ของพี่อาร์ตี้เนี่ยเป็นเหล็ก
เอาเป็นเหล็กต่างกันเหล็กเนี่ยมีที่หนีบ
ผมก็เป็นเหล็กอ๋อเอาเหล็กไปทำอะไรครับ
เชิญเอาเหล็กไปทำอะไรครับปืนใหญ่ค่ะอ๋อ
อ๋อเอาเหล็กไปทำปืนใหญ่
น้า
เหมือนไหมปืนใหญ่
ที่เวลาใส่แต่เห็นรู้ก็เข้าไป 5 ใส่รูป
เด็กกลมๆก็ไปอ่ะ
แล้วเขาก็จะยิงทรายยิงออกมา
นุ่มขอเพียงก็จะทำปืนใหญ่คำปืนใหญ่ไปทำไม
ครับถ้าไม่ chain ถึงอยากอยากทำปืนใหญ่
ข้าคนอื่นไงคะพี่อาร์ตี้อ๋ออ๋ออยากทำ
และแล้วเขาก็เอาไว้ฆ่าคนที่มีสีขาวกับสี
ดำมาอ๋อ
เพราะเขาคิดว่าอ่าคนที่มีสีขาวสีดำจะมา
ฆ่าเขาเขาก็เลยฆ่าคนที่มีสีขาวสีดำก่อน
แบบนั้นใช่ไหมครับ
แล้วในในภาค 2 เนี้ยเขาก็ไปขอ
เขาก็บอกได้ว่าเจนี่แหละที่เป็นค่ามี
แพนด้า
ฆ่าหมีแพนด้าหลายๆตัวนะอ๋ออ๋อค่ะมีกันได้
เยอะเลยใช่ไหมครับ
เพราะเขาคิดว่าแพนด้ามีสีขาว
มีสีขาวกับสีดำขับเลยค่าแพนด้าได้ไม่มี
แพนด้ามาฆ่าเช่นขอกลับ
ใช่แล้วเขาก็รู้ได้ว่า
โอเป็นหมีแพนด้าที่
หมอเขาก็จะมาฆ่าโป่งหมอก็จะมาฆ่าโปรด้วย
ห้าวแล้วโปรทำยังไงครับ Oppo รู้ว่าเชิญ
จะมาฆ่าโปร่งโอทำยังไงครับพี่ขอสู้ๆฮึใช้
กับกูสู้
kane เขามีลูกน้องเป็นหมาป่านะคะอ๋อครับ
เช่นมีลูกน้องหลายคนได้ไหมครับ
ใช่ 5 มีลูกน้องหลายคนที่จะมาช่วยกันช่วย
กันฆ่าโปรค่าแพนด้านี่ไหมครับ
[เพลง]
อย่าลืมหารูปน้องเคนแล้วข้าได้ไหมข้าได้
ไหม
เป็นเป็นหมาอ๋อว้าวตัวนี้เป็นหมาป่าน่า
กลัวมากหมาป่าหมาป่าและหลายตัว
มีป่าหลายตัวเลยที่จะมาฆ่าโปร
ให้หมาป่าไปฆ่า Pro และขอขอบคุณสู้ๆกัน
อยู่มาปากโปสู้ๆเข้ากัน
โห่ก็เลยเห็น
เห็นเห็นอร่อยครับ
เห็นไลน์เห็นไลน์ที่หมาป่า
เห็นที่แขนเห็นผอมอินไลน์อยู่ที่แขนหมา
ป่ามี LINE อยู่ที่แขนเป็นลายอะไรครับ
ไลน์อะไร
เป็นลายสีแดงๆๆ
ไม่รู้ว่าคืออะไรนะแต่ว่ามันเป็นสีแดงๆ
[เพลง]
เพิ่งจะเป็นสีแดงๆเนี้ยเป็นลายสีแดงๆอยู่
ที่แขนหมาป่าใช่ไหมครับขอมาอยู่ที่หมาป่า
ฟ้าวบอกก็เลยจำได้มาก
เมื่อก่อนโปรเคยเห็นอ๋อ Go เคยเห็นลายนี้
แล้วอ่ะติดตั้งแต่ตอนเป็นเด็กๆ
ครับ
แล้วก็จำได้ว่าโปรมีแม่
กลับแม่เป็นแพนด้าเหมือนกันกับชายาแล้ว
แม่มีลายนี้ด้วยเหรอครับแม่มีลายนี้นึง
แม่ไม่มีไรนี้แต่จำได้ว่าตอนเด็กๆมีคนที่
มีลายนี้
ขอวิ่งจะฆ่าโบว์ค่าแม่โป่ง
ไลน์นี่แหละเนาะปรเจำลายนี้ได้โอเค
อ้าว
กูก็เลยกลับไปกลับไปที่บ้านไปถามพ่อของ
โปรขออ๋อไปถามพ่อเป็ดใช่ครับไปถามพ่อเป็ด
ใช่ค่ะอ่ะขอถามพ่อเป็ด
ว่าโปรมีพ่อ
มีพ่อมีแม่
แล้วโปร - เป็ด
เป็ดมาเป็นข้อของโปรได้ยังไง
หรือ
เป็ดก็เลยเล่าเล่าเล่าให้ฟังว่าเป็ดก็ไม่
ใช่พ่อโปรขอเป็ดไม่ใช่พ่อของปอกับเป็ด
เป็ดเอ่อเลี้ยงโปรมาตอนที่โปรเป็นเด็กใช่
ไหมครับน้าพอก็เลยคิดนี่ออกก็เลยคิดว่า
พ่อคิดว่าเป็นเป็นพ่อหน้าแต่จริงๆแล้ว
เป็ดเป็ดไม่ใช่พ่อของโปร
ก็เลยบอกว่าไปเจอโปรในในถังถังหัวไชเท้า
อ๋อตอนที่โปเปนแต่เด็กตอนที่พ่อเห็นโปร
ครั้งแรกตอนที่พ่อเห็นโบว์ครั้งแรกหนัง
โป็หญิงตัวเล็กๆอยู่โออยู่ในถังอยู่ในถัง
เล็กๆนะอ่าแล้วข้อเนี่ยไปเจอไปเจอโปรอยู่
ใช่ค่ะขับเพราะว่าโปรโปรกับแม่มาด้วยกัน
แล้วแม่ก็เลยเอาโปรใส่ในถังหัวไชเท้าหัว
เทเท้าจะเป็นอย่างนี้ฮะ
โอเคเท้าจะเป็นสีขาวใช่ครับเหมือนกับหัว
แครอทแต่ว่าเป็นสีขาว
5 ถ้าแครอทจะเป็นสีส้มได้มั้ย
ครับแต่ไม่เห็น
ใจกับไม่ใช่ไม่เหมือนกัน
เถอะศรี
ศิลป์ขาวสีคะมีใบสีเขียวอ่ะโอเคนะครับ
ราคาก็
เป็ดก็เลยเลี้ยงเลี้ยงโปรจนโตเป็นหมี
แพนด้าตัวใหญ่ๆเลย
จะได้
แล้วที่ดีปลูกก็เลยต้องไปสู้สู้กับเพนน้อ
หมอเชนจะตามมาฆ่าโปรโฮก็เลยต้องสู้ใช่ไหม
ครับโปรไม่ยอมให้ข้าก็เลยสู้กับเชนครับ
หน้า
แล้วที่นี่เขาก็เลยไปหาเช่น
ชายหาเช่นเชนก็คิดว่าตัวเองสู้สู้สู้โป่ง
โปรไม่ได้อ้าวเหรอครับเชนสู้โปรไม่ได้
ครับที่ตับได้ไหมหาเทรนก็เลยทำปืนใหญ่ไง
อ๋ออ๋อทำปืนใหญ่เอาไว้เอาไว้ฆ่าคนที่จะมา
ฆ่าเชนทร์
อาหมอยิงใส่โปรใช่ไหมอ่ะยิ่งใส่โปรแล้ว
โปรเป็นไงครับยิงถูกโตไหม
ผู้ค่ะยิ่งถูกโปรเป็นเมือง
เมืองของเชน
เมืองของเจนเขาจะมีน้ำน้ำอยู่รอบรอบๆอ๋อ
ครับ
ลบปืนใหญ่จะอยู่ข้างใน
ปืนใหญ่
ยิงออกมาข้างนอกขอกลับ
ใช่แล้วโปรก็จนยิงโอโห้ก็โดนยิงอันนี้โปร
นะกูก็โดนยิงแล้วก็ออกมาข้างนอก
กระเด็นออกมาข้างนอกอันนี้โป
เชนก็คิดว่าอ๋อก็คิดว่าจะฆ่าโผได้อ๋อ
เพราะปองโดนยิง
โป๊โดนยิงแล้วโปรตายไหมไม่ตายใช่ไหมครับ
หมอพอไม่เป็นอะไรแต่เช่นคิดว่าคิดว่ายิง
โปรได้แล้วโปรจนตายตะโปไม่ตายก็ไม่ตาย
แล้วไม่ทำยังไงครับโปรทำยังไง
เวลาที่เช่นยิงลูกลูกปืนใหญ่ออกมาป่าวใช่
ไหมคะ
ลืมลบอันนี้ก่อน
เวลาที่เคนยิงปืนใหญ่ออกมา
โอไปอยู่ข้างนอกแล้ว
ก็รับลูกปืนใหญ่ค่ะพี่บอลครับกรุ๊ปพื้น
ใหญ่ได้เหรอครับว้าวโปเก่งจังเลยเอาแล้ว
จะเอาลูกปืนใหญ่
เขวี้ยงกลับไปอ๋ออ๋อกลับไปหาเช่น
หาเช่น
เราก็ตู้มขอเชิญรับได้ไหมเช่นรับไม่ได้
ใช่ไหม
รถเชียงก็ยิงปืนใหญ่ออกมาอีกต้อง
โป๊ก็รับลูกลูกปืนใหญ่แล้วก็เขวี้ยงกลับ
ไปกลับไปอีกอ๋อ
ตู้อา
น้องเมืองของเชนก็พังอ๋ออ๋อฟังพวกลูกปืน
ใหญ่ที่ยิงออกมานั่นเองนะครับเพราะโปรก็
รับแล้วขว้างกลับคืนไปที่เมืองของเช่นอ๋อ
อย่าอาบแล้วเชิญเป็นไงเชนแท้ไหมครับทีนี้
เพลงก็
ยังโดนเห็นดูหนังเมืองคานน์อ๋อชายพอโดน
ลูกปืนพัง
ขับแต่เขาก็เลยเอาดาบขึ้นมาค่ะ
มีด่าขึ้นมา
จะเอามาฆ่าโปรขอว้าวครับตอนนี้ปรกจับเข้า
ไปในโปรกลับเข้าไปในเมืองนะคะน้องปอก็
เข้าไปนิ้วนางแล้วทีนี้
ใช่เราก็ไปสู้ๆกับเชนเชนก็ใช้ดาบฟัน
ฟันฟันฟันแล้วที่นี่ฟันไปลบปืนใหญ่ค่ะฟัน
ไปโดน
ปืนใหญ่
มันจะมีเชือกเฮียตี้เชือกอาบเชือกเชือก
หลายๆอันแล้วเชนเขาก็เลยเอามีดาบเนี่ยไป
ฟันเชือก
ไปฟันเชือกจุ๊บจุ๊บๆๆก็ขาดอ่ะเชือกขาด
เชือกขาดใหญ่
ปืนใหญ่นะคะก็มาทับเชนน้อ
เอาปืนใหญ่หนักมากใช่ไหมพอตอนที่มีเชือก
อยู่ปืนใหญ่ก็โอเคเพราะไม่มีเชือกแล้วนี้
ปืนใหญ่ก็ก๊อปลิ้งไปไปครับเช่นอ๋อแล้ว
เชิญเป็นเหตุครับเจนตาให้เลยเพราะโดนปืน
ใหญ่ทัพอายอ่ะอ่าเรื่องนี้ก็เลยจบ
สนุกก็คือเคนก็ถูกฆ่าไม่คนที่มีสีขาวอ๋อ
ก็สีดำโปรนั่นเองที่มีสีขาวกับสีดำ
คือแบบที่อ่ะตีตี้คิดว่าชื่อคลิปว่าถ้า
อ่าเอ่อถ้าเชนไม่ไปฆ่าแพนด้าก่อนโปรก็ไม่
ฆ่าเฉน
ใช่ไหม
แต่ว่าเรื่องนี้เป็นเพราะเชนจะไปฆ่า
แพนด้าไปค่าโปรก่อนเขาก็เลยต้องมาถ้าเช่น
โป๊ก็เลยต้องสู้โว้ก็เลยต้องสู้เพราะว่า
ไม่อยากถูกฆ่าก็เลยสู้
ๆ
อันนี้ก็คือจบกังฟูแพนด้า 2  5 จบกังฟู
แพนด้า 2 แล้วว้าวสนุกไหมครับนักเรียน
นักเรียนมีนักเรียนคนไหนนักเรียนคนไหนที่
เคยเคยดูกังฟูแพนด้าแล้วบ้างขี้ใน
คอมเม้นท์บอกครวญตีหน่อยบอกครูเรียมว่า
เคยดูแล้วเคยดูแล้วนะครับ
วันนี้เวลาก็หมดแล้วค่ะเนื้อหาๆเวลาหมด
แล้วหือๆเดี๋ยวคลิปหน้าเรากลับมาเจอกัน
ใหม่นะครับอ่ะครัวตี้แล้วก็ก็เรียนจะมี
เรื่องอะไรมันเล่าให้ฟังเดี๋ยวค่อยติดตาม
กันนะครับในช่องคอม princesa ไทยช่องนี้
นะครับ 5 ท่าดูคลิปนี้แล้ว
อ้าโอเคทำได้ดูคลิปนี้ล่ะชอบนะชอบอย่าลืม
กด like กด Subscribe ข้างล่างนี้กด
Subscribe ให้ด้วยกดแชร์ด้วยกดแชร์นะ
ครับโอเคแล้วกลับมาเจอกันใหม่คลิปหน้า
ครับวันนี้ลาไปก่อนครับสวัสดีครับบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีครับแล้วเปี่ยนซื้อกับน้องเรียม
บ๊ายบาย